Authors have an obligation to make sure their
paper is based on original, never before published,
research.
Intentionally submitting or re-submitting
work for duplicate publication is considered
a breach of publishing ethics.
Simultaneous submission occurs when a person
submits a paper to different publications
at the same time, which can result in more
than one journal publishing that particular
paper.
Duplicate or multiple publication occurs when
two or more papers, without full cross-reference,
share essentially the same hypotheses, data,
discussion points, and/or conclusions.
This can occur in varying degrees including
literal duplication, partial but substantial
duplication, or even duplication by paraphrasing.
One of the main reasons duplicate publication
of original research is considered unethical,
is that it can result in inadvertent double
counting or inappropriate weighting of the
results of a single study, which distorts
the available evidence.
There are certain situations in which the
publishers of two journals might agree in
advance to use the "duplicate work".
These include:
• Combined editorials (e.g. about a plagiarism
case involving the two journals).
• Clinical guidelines, position statements.
• Translations of articles, provided that
prior approval has been granted by the first
Publisher, and that full and prominent disclosure
of its original source is given at the time
of submission.
The main rule of thumb is that articles submitted
for publication must be original and must
not have been submitted to any other publication.
At the time of submission, authors must disclose
any details of related papers, also when in
a different language, similar papers in press,
and translations.
The “slicing” of research that would form
one meaningful paper into several different
papers is called "salami publication" or "salami
slicing".
Unlike duplicate publication, which involves
reporting the exact same data in two or more
publications, salami slicing involves breaking
up or segmenting a large study into two or
more publications.
These segments are referred to as "slices"
of a study.
As a general rule, as long as the "slices"
of a broken up study share the same hypotheses,
population, and methods, this is not acceptable
practice.
The same "slice" should never be published
more than once.
The reason, according to the U.S. Office of
Research Integrity, salami slicing can result
in a distortion of the literature by leading
unsuspecting readers to believe that data
presented in each salami slice is derived
from a different subject sample.
This not only skews the "scientific database"
but it creates repetition that wastes readers'
time as well as the time of editors and reviewers,
who must handle each paper separately.
Further, it unfairly inflates the author's
citation record.
There are instances where data from large
clinical trials and epidemiological studies
cannot be published simultaneously, or are
such that they address different and distinct
questions with multiple and unrelated endpoints.
In these cases, it is legitimate to describe
important outcomes of the studies separately.
However, each paper should clearly define
its hypothesis and be presented as one section
of a much larger study.
In summary, duplicate publication and salami
slicing are unacceptable practices and should
be avoided at all costs as it can give an
unfair advantage to some scientists.
By increasing the number of publications they
can list on their resume, scientists and researchers
can progress faster in their careers or receive
more funding than they actually merit.
Additionally, salami slicing also leads to
a waste of time for readers and reviewers
as they have to go through repetitive content.
It also leads to distortion of scientific
literature.